warm up with some delicious titty milk
we are less than a month away until the
new season of the boys and our corporate
overlords over at amazon have blessed us
with yet another trailer in this video
we'll be breaking it down link in the
description if you haven't seen it yet
but please make sure to come back i am
lonelier than homelander without a mom
we start on the cameron coleman hour
which if you've been paying attention to
the not-so-secret vot international
youtube channel there are clips of his
show it's a total satire on fox news and
hosts like sean hannity and tucker
carlson homelanders making the rounds on
all the vaude affiliated news networks
talking about how he fell in love with
the wrong woman no doubt a nod to
stormfront and her ties to actual nazis
remember that according to the press
conference at the end of season 2
stormfront is still alive in an
undisclosed location there are a ton of
fun little easter eggs here like the
vaught women's network vots version of
telemundo and the premiere of the dawn
of the seven which you'll remember our
soups acting in in season 2. i'm gay
you'll also notice that homelanders said
he spent quote the last year connecting
with himself so we can gauge that we are
about a year after the events of season
2. you'll also see stan edgar in the
back who if you've seen my season 2
ending explained video i've theorized
could be frederick vaught in disguise as
starlight says there's something wrong
with homelander we see him focusing on
himself in the mirror and maybe it's
just me but it kind of looks like he has
a bruise along his right cheek you'll
notice all these generic american
history type paintings on the wall which
actor anthony starr has said are meant
to reflect his character not having his
own identity even in his own apartment
these are paintings vaught wishes
homelander can aspire to here's
starlight and homelander and you'll
recall that starlight was brought back
into the seven after stan edgar spun
this story to the press that it was her
and maeve who brought down stormfront oh
no here's homelander milking a cow
nothing good could come from that nor
him gently caressing a blood stain on
what appears to be a hospital bed could
this be stormfront we know she's still
alive at the end of season 2 but in what
sort of condition last season we met a
soup named gekko who had regenerative
powers and was often tested on by vaught
if fat found a way to synthesize this
regenerative power it's totally possible
stormfront could make a complete
recovery starlight vents her frustration
over how unhinged homelander has become
notice how it looks like she's on some
sort of film or tv set this is likely
the set of american hero where starlight
is the host a reality tv program which
pits superheroes against one another for
the two open spots in the seven here we
have butcher meeting up with ryan the
two formed a special relationship last
season and ryan has been put in
protective custody to keep him hidden
from his father homelander it looks as
though he's still under the care of
grace mallory and judging by these
british darts it looks like butcher
still isn't too fond of homelander i
like the added touch of the bulldog the
same breed as his dog terror apparently
he's been following orders from huey who
currently holds the position of senior
analyst for the federal bureau of
superhuman affairs remember at the end
of season 2 he went to work for victoria
newman who is the director of the fpsa
and in a underground parking lot butcher
seems to be unleashing some of that good
old vigilante justice to a character
known as gunpowder a retired superhero
who is very very pro-gun frenchie and
kimiko are seen here expect them to be
closer than ever as late last season
when she started to learn her special
form of sign language vaught tower which
is actually roy thompson hall in toronto
i did a whole video on the shooting
locations which you can also check out
later and here is mother's milk hugging
his daughter who is dressed as starlight
in her very own superhero themed
birthday party i'm really curious why
she's wearing a clock around her neck it
could just be something totally random
but if you have any ideas let me know in
the comments this has to be really
conflicting for mother's milk since he
knows how corrupt and terrible these
superheroes are and having his daughter
look up to them it's just really weird
black noir is back after almost being
killed by an allergic reaction to an
almond joy he's back in the seventh
chamber sharpening what appears to be a
sword alongside an assortment of other
knives here's ashley who we saw losing
her hair in season two witnessing a body
fall from a skyscraper now the editing
makes it seem like it's homelander who
did this considering the next shot is of
him flying down a building but you'll
notice that these are two completely
different buildings she makes the
cameraman beside her put down the camera
so this could be a pr stunt gone
terribly wrong the building in the
background here is where homelander and
stormfront had all of their big rallies
and it looks like homelander has amassed
quite the support of group of followers
considering the backlash he's been
facing they wear t-shirts that read
sorry snowflake i'm with homelander and
there's even a guy who kind of looks
like that viking who stormed the capital
now if you look closely you can also see
what appears to be a statue knocked over
on the ground i think this is the
soldier boy statue we saw in the same
location in season two we know that
soldier boy will be a character in this
season of the show he's kind of like a
captain america parody so if this crowd
knocked over his statue it hints at some
sort of rift between him and homelander
hughie here expresses his frustrations
in taking down vaude he thought he could
do it the right way but because he says
the system is rigged they have to do it
quote your way could he be talking to
butcher victoria newman or someone else
entirely frenchie here looks to be
kidnapped and hears kimiko going
absolutely wild against what appears to
be some sort of gangsters in the vanity
fair interview she says this fight
involves her beating them up using
dildos now this is our first shot of
victoria newman in vaught tower
alongside starlight and starlight seems
a little uneasy we aren't exactly sure
what victoria's endgame is here
especially after it was revealed she was
season 2's head exploding soup now maeve
tells butcher she thinks she has
something that can stop homelander for
good it's not the video footage of
homelander taking down that passenger
plane in season 1 that she previously
used as blackmailed this is something
different a compound v that turns you
into a soup for 24 hours here's our
first shot of soldier boy in the past
because it has been confirmed this is
young gunpowder beside him there's a
memorandum here from vaught about a
raymond patriarca who was a real-life
mobster up until his death in 1984. but
why is there a photo of soldier boy
attached was he working with them or
working to bring this mobster down
here's frenchie enjoying some tea
reading a file maybe it's that file with
soldier boy in it now i can't quite make
it out but that does look like there's
an fbsa file folder in the background so
it could be that huey is supplying the
boys with confidential information a
better shot of soldier boy and his
shield and we really get a sense that
soldier boy has some anger issues now
this is really interesting we have
soldier boy with this long beard later
in the trailer we'll see him emerging
from some sort of cryo chamber just like
captain america was put on ice for
decades and it looks like it's butcher
and the boys who are responsible for
this maybe they think soldier boy is the
only one capable of taking homelander on
we see butcher infiltrating what looks
like an abandoned facility where soldier
boy has been stored and it looks as
though butcher has taken the 24-hour
soup compound allowing him the ability
of laser eyes it's here we also get a
glimpse of soldier boy and his ability
of the energy blast something kimiko
saves frenchie from we'll also see
starlight and mother's milk take on
soldier boy at the vaught news network
where soldier boy will use his shield to
fight off starlight's power if you look
very closely you'll also see maeve
fighting someone in the background it's
too blurry to make out who but it looks
like it could be either homelander or
the crimson countess who we'll get to in
a bit this giant explosion here looks
like it could be the result of soldier
boy we'll later see butcher and huey
investigate its aftermath mother's milk
then reminds butcher that the boys do
what they do because no one should have
that kind of crazy superhero power which
hints that butcher may become addicted
to the compound he's given i mean we see
him literally shooting up like a junkie
interesting fact whoever ends up taking
this 24-hour compound does not know what
power they will be given when they take
it in this shot here you'll notice what
appears to be two bullet holes in the
chest i wonder if his powers also make
him impervious to bullets we'll see
gunpowder shoot a bullet and i think
this all happens in that parking lot
where butcher beats the crap out of him
ryan is here with those glowing red eyes
it'll be interesting to see if he'll
cultivate his powers considering how
terrible he was at controlling them last
season here's our first look at the
crimson countess in the trailer a soup
who can control fire she seems to be in
the same location as soldier boy in this
fly-like soup taking down what could be
south american gorilla fighters kimiko
and frenchie in a hospital dance scene
it has been confirmed that one of the
episodes this season will be a musical
the deep is back at vaude hq he was
turned away from the seven so it'll be
interesting if he's found a way back in
black noir draws something we know from
the teaser that this is buster beaver a
chuck e cheese type mascot who has his
very own commercials on the cameron
coleman show here's a train channeling
his inner kendall jenner doing a
commercial for his new soda this does
not look good but here's frenchie's head
attached to a bike lock now i couldn't
really make this out of my monitor but
the editing makes it look like it's
mother's milk smashing some sort of bat
over an impervious butcher if that's
what this is it further proves the
theory he's developed some sort of steel
skin this poor guy is about to get his
entire body exploded it looks as though
this could be victoria newman enacting
some sort of justice against someone who
tried to mug her in this alley i mean
that's what i got out of it it looks
like there's a bag and a knife in the
ground there and the trailer ends with
butcher unleashing those laser eyes on
gunpowder and that's pretty much it for
the trailer i want to hear your thoughts
about the boys season 3 they're saying
it's the most bonker season yet and i
hope you'll consider liking and
subscribing as i hope to cover the
season for more bad takes you can follow
me on instagram and twitter at
thingstoryt until next time remember
you